foreign
[Music]
ly enough the thing that has been going
through my head
pretty much every day
for about two weeks now is this clip
from Doctor Who
and I was having such a nice day so
I'm at a point
where
I desire nothing
in the world
so much is never to have to think about
anything even vaguely connected with a
certain children's book series author
ever again and yet because of
so much other nonsense
whether it be
uh the mass reporting falsely of my Tick
Tock account to the point that it got
banned whether it be the pylon of
comments on a short right here on
YouTube to the tune of thousands a day
many of which flatly uh saying that I
should commit violence against myself
uh I'd really just love to not
but then there's the BBC
and while Rowling will not
be the main feature of this video
she does factor in which again just kind
of adds to the sense that like I really
don't want to think about you people say
we're obsessed with her good luck try to
escape her if you are a trans person
with a social media presence
anyways if you had not heard
the BBC has issued an apology in regards
to an interview that took place on BBC
Radio 4. the apology that they issued
basically amounts to
we're sorry we didn't defend JK Rowling
against accusations of being transphobic
the full context basically amounts to an
interview that took place and the person
being interviewed mentioned Rowling's
transphobia which
despite all immediately available
evidence should really not be a point of
dispute anymore if you want to side with
her and say that you support what she
says
that's your prerogative but the
continued denial that it even is
transphobia is staggering at this point
and I am not going to turn this into a
three-hour plus thing trying to catalog
it for your sake if you want to do that
there is Jesse genders video three and a
half hours and well worth the watch
that's a more comprehensive thing if you
don't have three and a half hours here's
the time code of that video that
actually specifically covers the major
incidents that again really make this
not a matter for debate
now it's also worth noting that when the
guest on that radio show said that
the uh host didn't just let it go
his words were well she wouldn't
consider herself transphobic which
maybe she wouldn't she would certainly
claim publicly that she's not that's her
uh official stance whether or not she
actually
believes that that's a whole other
argument that I absolutely am not
delving into but
the reason I'm noting that is because
there was not no challenge
there was
a small pushback was it him stopping the
interview dead and going wait I require
that you absolutely lay out every point
that proves that she is transphobic well
no that would have been an absurd way to
conduct an interview but that's
basically what the mountain of
complaints
have expressed should have happened
and many of them demanding that there
now be equal time given to the opposite
perspective I.E arguments that she isn't
transphobic despite
reality
again this video and the reason I feel
the need to make it is actually not
about her at all
it's about the BBC
because the BBC
if you watch my doctor who content you
know that pretty much all of it starts
with this warning at the front end
because the BBC has been a problem for a
while
whether it be their platforming of a
woman who literally called for
transgenocide and even after removing
her content from the article not
properly addressing the other fallacies
and uh inaccurate reporting contained
within that article
ignoring the thousands of complaints
sent in about various aspects of that
article
there's uh that same pinned comment I
mentioned is going to be down below this
so if you want to track that whole thing
there's your means to do so but that was
hardly an isolated incident there was an
article a few months back about Elon
Musk transgender daughter and the second
sentence of the article is her dead name
which while the article was about her
change in gender her dead name is not
relevant information the fact that she
has transitioned is all that needs to be
said the BBC has ignored calls for
responsibility protests they have
removed the Stonewall organization as a
consultant to attempt to combat issues
of discrepancy they have forbade their
employees from attending Pride events
the BBC is already a mess
but with each new incident
it makes something harder for me
and that is to continue to talk about
Doctor Who
at all
because while I will often with some
reluctance continue to talk about JK
Rowling the figure I don't talk about
Harry Potter the property
anymore
I used to have Harry Potter items up on
this shelf and they're not there
uh as I've said publicly publicly
elsewhere I have not actually fully
gotten rid of them but they are packed
away
up in the attic along with the books and
the movies
the reason I haven't gotten rid of them
is because pretty much all of them were
gifts so I have an emotional attachment
from the people who gave them to me
people who
actually know me and love me
but I can't look at any of it anymore
and I haven't talked about that kind of
stuff in a long time
but I continue to talk about Doctor Who
yes with that warning at the front but I
do continue to talk about it
and it's starting to feel a little gross
as
the BBC completely cows cow Taos to a
group of people not saying how dare you
fail to push back against someone
calling JK Rowling transphobic but
saying you didn't push back hard enough
the BBC is very much on their side in
this issue consistently
the news arm of the BBC
virtually never
Advocates or presents evenly the
positions on transphobia its coverage is
virtually always weighted in favor of
gen of gender critical people like JK
Rowling but that's not enough
it's not enough that that position is
favored
the gender critical movement of which JK
Rowling is the biggest figurehead
they want the BBC to advocate for their
position
to argue
their position to argue their points for
them on their broadcasts
and if they don't to give them a
platform to do it themselves
and the BBC
has issued an apology for that
while that article that I mentioned
before
remains up
with only the tiniest changes to it the
BBC
is on their side
and that's becoming
more and more evident so that brings me
back to Doctor Who I have continued to
talk about Doctor Who with that warning
at the front end
and honestly it's distinctly possible
that warning at the front end cost me
views
there are probably people out there who
see that warning and then turn the video
off
either because
um they are upset that I'm bringing
attention to it or because they're sick
of seeing it or what have you honestly
I'm sick of seeing it I would love to
never see it again I would love not to
have to keep putting it there
foreign
but
I leave it there
because it's what I have to do to not
feel like garbage
because
I've talked about blatantly
how continuing to promote Harry Potter
related material
is
empowering transphobia
and that's simply because the owner of
that IP the person whose entire clout is
based on being the creator of that
wields every ounce of clout and
attention that grants her against trans
people
and so whether you hold transphobic
beliefs in your heart or not and you may
very well not
contributing to that property still
empowers as I said the figurehead of
transphobia in the UK
it just does
regardless of your intent regardless of
your beliefs regardless of who you are
as a person
buying Harry Potter stuff doesn't make
you transphobic it doesn't make you a
bad person but it is a contribution
towards transphobia
I believe that very firmly
and I'm having to more closely examine
Doctor Who
and it's not a one-to-one
there are lots of aspects that are
actually quite different
for one thing rolling is a single person
and her actions are incredibly clear and
she is the one person who will always
benefit from everything with a Harry
Potter name so long as she owns the uh
the original Ip rights to it that will
always be the case this is always the
person who will benefit from the money
and the attention the BBC is an
organization with different people at
the head it can shift it can change it's
this way now it might be different in
the future one could argue JK Rowling
might change but I think it's far more
likely for the heads of a corporation to
be swapped out and for there to be a
shift then for any given individual to
have a change of heart
but there's that there's the fact that
my issues are with the BBC News arm and
not the BBC drama department where
Doctor Who is produced there's the fact
that Russell T Davis current showrunner
is an outspoken trans Ally
is to kill that is so helpful to see
and additionally muddying the waters
there's the fact that the BBC doesn't
actually produce Doctor Who anymore the
BBC has moved production to battle
Studios which is owned by Sony
and Disney is now in the mix because
Disney is contributing some funds in
exchange for uh getting uh the broadcast
the broadcast streaming rights for
Doctor Who going forward for the time
being and exactly how this potentially
muddies the waters in terms of the
income and the revenue generated by
Doctor Who because one would imagine
um Sony through battle studio in Disney
through because not only is it getting
the streaming rights it's contributing
money they're getting a piece of
something so that's less of it that's
going directly to the BBC these are all
things that make it less of a straight
line and less of a clear-cut situation
than Harry Potter and Rowling but I
would be lying if I did not admit to a
much simpler reality than that
I can't afford to not talk about Doctor
Who
Doctor Who is what this channel is built
on it's what I talk about most often
and I took a hit to my income
when I stopped talking about Harry
Potter because those videos performed
quite well
and while some might argue well you now
make videos about JK Rowling doesn't
that replace it well
I used to habitually make videos on
Harry Potter I don't about JK Rowling
because it's draining and I hate talking
about it so no it's it's actually not
equivocal but there's also another
aspect to that which I'll get to in just
a minute
but I have bills to pay
I have to eat I have a kid
I have a kid I have to clothe and take
care of
I have taxes I have to pay
and I cannot afford
to Simply drop Doctor Who
from
what I do here on YouTube
I won't lie
if I had another property
that was viable for me to shift to focus
on more that was as reliable as the
income I get from Doctor Who content I
would consider starting to shift that
but the other stuff that I talk about
when I talk about it even the franchise
stuff like Star Wars Marvel it doesn't
perform as well
it performs decently enough but not as
well never has
so
I can't afford that hit
does that make me hypocritical
probably
to the extent that anyone stuck in the
global capitalist system is hypocritical
by nature of a system that is designed
to exploit so when you try and stand up
against exploitation and harm you still
have to contend with the fact that you
are contributing to it in some way
possibly even contributing directly to
the very kind of harm you're trying to
stand up against
the thing is
the other stuff that performs well
it's one-off stuff the video I down good
Omens perform very well I can't crank
out a monthly uh to weekly content about
that
Marvel doesn't perform as well Star Wars
doesn't perform as well Sandman
performed very well when I covered that
again that was a one-off
I don't have something with the depth of
content
the depth of stuff to be able to talk
about the wealth of
material to draw from
that performs as well for me as Doctor
Who
the only thing that I do on this channel
with any degree of consistency that
performs better than Doctor Who
is stuff about celebrity drama and
Scandal and from a Strictly Business
perspective I could theoretically pivot
to that but that would make me hate my
work
because I don't like making those videos
and part of the reason I'm able to is a
nine times out of ten I am approaching
them from the perspective of how does
this impact the general PR what projects
are in the works you know the company's
evolved I I take a more PR and business
focused view of it as opposed to a
moralizing view more often than not
that's one way in which
um I swear that the other way is it's
not the only thing I do in between the
times that I feel obligated to talk
about people like Ezra Miller Joss
Whedon John Barrowman Amber Heard and
yes JK Rowling in between those I get to
talk about stuff that I love
like Doctor Who
because I do still love this show
this property
I sell so much to explore within it
and the only thing that I could pivot to
that would not completely
tank my income
would be to turn this into a full-time
what's going on with this celebrity oh
what's the gossip what's the buzz
Channel
and I would hate myself if I did that
I would hate what I do
and the privilege I have right now is
that it most of the time I love what I
do and Doctor Who is still a big part of
loving what I do
I guess I'm just at a point where
if Doctor Who were to ever be canceled
there's a part of me that wow there's
the financial part of me that would
panic but there's another part of me
that would be relieved because I will no
longer have to worry about
am I obligated to keep talking about
this property or not this video
ultimately is
me rambling me letting you in and me
not even justifying I don't think
explaining
because there is a difference between an
explanation of justification and an
excuse and
I'm not trying to make excuses
for continuing to talk about a BBC
property when the BBC continues to lean
into cow Tao and regurgitate
gender critical people and their talking
points
but
I still have to pay bills
I need to be able
to sit down to do a work day
and not dread it this is the position
that
this system puts us in
the reason a phrase like no ethical
consumption under capitalism exists it's
not meant to be a Doomer phrase It's Not
Meant To Be A oh everything hurts
someone so why bother trying to do
anything good quote unquote
the purposes of that phrase is to point
out how deeply intertwined all these
things are
you want to try to avoid contributing to
something that's going to do damage good
luck
and Disney's involvement
doesn't uncomplicate Doctor Who makes it
more complicated because Disney's got
its own issues
I've got plenty of issues with Disney
but I also still talk about a lot of
Disney owned stuff
partially because I still enjoy it and I
need to find enjoyment if I'm going to
do this job
and partly because
it's what people are interested in
hearing from me
I don't have the degree of support
on this platform on patreon or anywhere
to be able to say I will not talk about
Doctor Who anymore until such time as
the BBC gets its act together which
frankly may never happen
so I'm stuck where I've been
the warning will continue to be there
this video will probably be added to the
pinned comment that goes on those videos
I just needed to say out loud it's
getting harder
it's getting harder
to be okay
with this
and for anyone who
is made uncomfortable by the fact that I
continue to talk about Doctor Who
because of all this
I get it
I'm uncomfortable about that
but my ability to break from it
is limited
I don't know where all this goes
I'm not announcing and I will stop
talking about Doctor Who on X date
because
well the simple fact is that when Doctor
Who is in the news
that is some of my better performing
stuff
and I don't have a surplus of income I
need what I get
it's all a mess
all of it
this is what happens this is what
twists things up this is honestly
in a lot of ways what I was asking
people to Grapple with
when I pointed out that buying Hogwarts
Legacy would contribute to transphobia
and this is me
grappling with that with the BBC
and what you determine on the other side
of that grapple that's on you and
obviously
I've given my indication of where I'm
landing for the time being in regards to
the BBC
and I know that grappling with these
things sucks
but
it's not healthy
individually or societally and
communally
to just
pretend the issue doesn't exist
that
that doesn't work
that's how we get into situations where
people will shout and debate the simple
fact that JK Rowling is transphobic
and demand an apology
that such a such a basic statement of
Truth
was not unchallenged vigorously
well here we are
and here we remain
I don't always have answers actually I
rarely have answers
but
I'll still be here
talking through the problems because
it's part of how I move forward and keep
doing what I do
thank you very much for your time
patreon is what supports this channel
and enables me to cover my bills because
while I can't afford to lose a huge
chunk of my YouTube income patreon is
far more
um reliable and a more significant chunk
of my income than YouTube is
so if you really want to help me out
that is the way to do it
but even if you can't there's links to
other stuff below other platforms that
I'm on assuming I haven't been banned on
them following a string of false
reportings that's really only been a
tick tock problem but yeah
who knows
but
in any case
whatever your thoughts are on all this
mess
drop them down in the comments and let's
talk about it
like share subscribe are also helpful if
you haven't already done that
but what I really want you to remember
especially if you are trying to Grapple
with all of this
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
[Music]
and now my thanks to my highest
supporters on patreon Robin Moore zuman
lafulla Tarak the thing that goes doing
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emu dalke Leo the Boyd Becky Sparks for
Nobby LAX the poodle
Tracy Scrabble angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett
thanks for your support and if you want
to get your name in the credits check
out the rewards on the patreon
[Music]
foreign